oh what are you doing you want to strike
out like that it was the 87 series and a
dog bites me in the ankle what do i do i
played with a broken ankle because there
is no i in t it might say on my baseball
card there's an eye in my name what they
don't know is that my real name is coach
slugger
making evil baseball so i just put a
japanese symbol for evil and it's on
fire so that's how you know it's evil we
just need to get better at not losing
our [ __ ] we lost the lens cap we had end
cap in those remotes
and an iphone
so shit's going missing yeah so talk
about a tripod head
tripod head tripod oh that's brandon i
think we should put this on here
no you want sound
you want a real nice mic today
[Music]
gabe sam what kind of preparation
does one need to shoot an anime baseball
video
none
because that's how we're shooting it no
preparation today
me a total shade like that
makes it so intense but the world series
there are zero outs the guy who's up to
bat first will be me b starts with me
swinging
i whiff it you catch it
three strikes you're out
[ __ ]
do we need uh
they don't have bases on the field by hp
[Music]
well it's truly an honor i'm a winner
regardless whether you want to lose just
because you made it here but i told my
mom i'd win
so i have to win you have to win you
don't you'll be a liar i don't mean
you're a loser and i'll bring great
shame upon my family so
minus losing the world series that's
what to take get ready for some shams
i mean have you read the script clint
you're the next one up
and you're not very good at hitting it
sucks you got a pair of legs on you so
you know if you can make the first you
can possibly make it home yeah dude i
feel so legit right now i know man you
look at your shoes dude
i'm jealous of your like knee-high
what's your name striker yeah they're
pretty sweet those are called your free
kirby kirby
caprice i wish i had some capris yeah
all right let me have it
oh can i have that let me get a pizza um
let me get a piece of real yeah yeah
it's a raspberry swirl pound cake oh
hold the icing on it
that's a good piece right there that's
literally the best piece you literally
[Laughter]
dude brown would be proud of you yeah
that's a jump ball that's against the
rules you know what they call a ball
like that preacher wrote brooklyn
dodgers 1955. peter would stand there
like this with his glove ball would be
in the mitt and putrio mastered the art
of the incredible fast spit
between his teeth
he was known for the best spitballs
there were then he'd go into the wind up
and you know he'd do the whole thing
follow through and that ball would go
like that the spin allowed it to
actually slide off your fingers in a way
that was very different a lot of times
guys will also do [ __ ] like outside of
their mitt a little bit of sandpaper
that look just like the mitt which would
allow you for your thumb and your finger
to hold it other guys will take vitalis
vitalism's stuff the guys used to slick
their back in their hairs like my dad
did it i've never done it but you'd see
guys going like this adjusting their
hats and going along the brim of their
hat like this and on the way back they
kind of touch their like that they touch
that greasy hair right there and then go
like this and they got a nice little
grease spot sure it's the same thing as
spitting but the problem is if an ump
even sees that and suspects it and he
just catch let me see that ball
when he looks at it
you get thrown out i don't really know
what i'm doing but i'm trying the
biggest challenge with this video is the
fact that it is also like mega abstract
and stylized specifically tuned to what
nico has in his brain cells up here so i
can make something that i think looks
pretty sweet and really just go all out
and then show it to nico and he's like i
have something completely different in
mind and we're trying to communicate so
that we minimize that these fire lines
on the bottom would be good to have
something that's dark in there also
literally it could just be hand-drawn
lines um like right now it's like energy
right it's like fire energy whereas if
you look at something like this there's
just straight up lines and i know this
is like we talked about doing blurs and
that kind of stuff but a little bit of
that artist touch like abstract
representations of motion versus like
you know blurry fire i'm not saying the
blurry fire looks bad the blurry fire
looks great all i'm saying is a touch of
something abstract
to truly make an anime
so we're probably just gonna record all
the lines except for like one specific
one one out
bottom of the ninth
and this is the world series
and they want me to go up
nice that might have been a little
intense
but hey go intense and bring it down
yeah all good
anyways the only reason i'd be wanting
this shot to have is just because this
is like the establishing shot of the
piece do you want me to like overlay
lines yeah basically just like laser-y
style darker lines
okay
yeah i'll try
i can do these effects but i have zero
intuition for these kind of effects i'm
an engineer i literally went to college
for mechanical engineering degree if you
want me to figure out the temperature
gradient between two pieces of metal
yeah sure i could figure that out but i
don't have an intuition for like making
things painterly you can use like
texture brushes that give it kind of
even paper quality so it's not just
perfect you send me a screen grab yeah
yeah i can do that i can do that
hopefully with our powers combined let
our powers combined
[Music]
so this fella by the name of ogre did
the music for this piece the soundtrack
and you want to like put some headphones
on and get lost in like an imaginary
world of fighting robots and pink neon
lights go check out ogre music also the
very end theme apparently somebody in
japan actually spends their time making
royalty-free anime themes and that was
quite a surprise his name is trial and
error so if you guys want to check out
his stuff as well link is in the
description i don't know where gabe went
we uh we coalesced into one being
[Applause]
how awesome and by that i mean he drew
some lines that were really cool then in
after effects and layer him through and
just have him cycle through and repeat
so it's like
like
if you guys recognize these two people
and know where we are you can just kind
of skip the rest of this but if you
don't
then you should keep watching this is
brandon and this is dee and we are at
the node studio here where we play tons
of sweet games we do vr stuff we do live
airsoft experiences d d everything so if
you like the stuff on sam and eco you'll
probably love all the stuff on node just
as much that's right click here on the
screen or a link in the description for
those of you on mobile go check it out
we promise use a whole bunch of cool
things for you to feast your eyeballs on
and just use up that data plan megabytes
yep and if you're halfway through a
comment right now it's like i've known
this for years just just delete that
comment we don't need it i mean not
everybody's like you yeah everybody
knows everything all the time
not everybody can know everything and if
you see any comments like that flag them
report them